personal question
what's the most you've ever cried to
like a piece of fiction
at all the most yeah
probably the second half of planet after
story like the last like six episodes i
was like continue like i was like
like episode like you know
14 15 i'm obviously not going to spoil
it yeah episode like around like episode
14 15 of planet after story like
something happens yeah and it's like
you break down crying and you think to
yourself
okay it's all out of my system yeah and
then the next episode starts and it's
just like [ __ ] man
why
and then it's just that yeah for the
rest of the episodes until it's over and
you're just a [ __ ] mess i just cried
everything there's a lot of future stuff
that isn't even center crier like what
don't i like this becky will be fighting
in my hurricane and i'll start crying
[Laughter]
it depends on my mood right yeah yeah
sometimes i'm like a [ __ ] rock and
it's like it could be like the worst
thing on earth yeah
it's really weird because i've found
myself and i think i i think this is
healthy because i've found myself
more easily crying towards pieces of
media and fictional pieces of media now
than i did like uh like five years yeah
five years ago everything yeah and i
think like the the thing like
the one that broke the camera was back
was like an ohana i'm like
i cried a lot
i think before anahana i don't think i
had ever
cried watching
an anime yeah i'm trying to think for me
it was weird it's like very early on
when i was watching a lot of anime like
yeah because i think i first cried at
clan ad and then it was just like a
chain reaction of like and then i
watched anahana and then i watched air
and then i watched all these shows that
made you cry yeah yeah and then for a
while i had this blank period where you
exhausted yourself maybe yeah and then
the one the work the one that broke the
camera's back for me was makia
makia
like there was so many like sad shows
that people were like right like i
didn't cry at the end of uh july and
april even though a lot of people did i
didn't either yeah i don't know i was
like am i weird for thinking that am i
just like overexposed to this kind of
media and then i and then i watch machia
on a [ __ ] plane tiny screen like this
with shitty like
yeah and like crying to like three
pixels and i was like and then the
ending to that just like destroyed me
and i was like why is it this one that
made me cry after all this it's it's
weird because before like i would any
time i would cry just cry towards
something that thing would be like
really really [ __ ] special to break
down the brick wall that i am but
nowadays
because i cry way more easily i don't
know it's weird sometimes i have like
empty cries where i cry and i'm just
like it's over and then i feel nothing
it's just like i don't know it's weird
like i i'm like i cry and i feel amazing
yeah right
like i ordered mcdonald's the other day
and i was like why did i do this i cried
you know i [ __ ] cried to demon slayer
and i was like
like the moment i feel sad i'm just like
have you ever ever had those cries
though where it doesn't feel like you've
released
wait you just feel shittier yeah do you
want my edging with tears not edgy
climax with tears no no there's those
times where you know you'd watch
something really sad and then you just
like let the emotions out and then after
your tears have subsided you're just
like oh all right i'm glad that's out
you know i feel good like all my
emotions all my emotional values out and
then there are some times where you
would start crying and then once the
tears of society you just like
man i'm now more sad than i was before
when i was like 15 with breakups i'd cry
i feel worse oh yeah yeah why don't you
leave me
you know getting going to funerals i i
wouldn't like even if i wasn't you know
because you know sometimes when you're
like 10 you didn't really understand
what's going on yeah and then maybe when
you get older you're like 15 16 and it's
like oh it's this person that you barely
ever met but you have to yeah because
you're all connected you know i wouldn't
i wouldn't know them so i wasn't like
sad but i would just get i would just
like cry because i'm like why is
everyone crying this is so sad
you cried because everyone around yeah
because if everyone else is crying
around me i'm like [ __ ] well i've got to
do it now
like you're just psyched about like mark
zuckerberg yeah but like i said like
this is human emotion i must cry now
sad.exe
about being around people who like when
a room is filled like sad energy it just
makes me get like that yeah it depends
for me right because like say for
example like the demon slayer movie
everyone was crying like [ __ ] crazy
at the end of that and i'm looking
around like oh it's now i have to cry
now
i can't get the tears out
like like to me if if like i cannot cry
to a piece of media if there's someone
else in the room like there's there's
there is a i can't show the mainland
sydney as well oh sydney as well
especially sydney
oh baby man you want a little no no no
no no no
no no because because like 10 minutes
before the tears even start forming in
my eyes she's bawling her eyes out
already she's sydney you're on cleanup
duty yeah yeah sydney is so emotionally
receptive that like she will start
crying five minutes before the sad
moments happen and she'll be like in
tears oh my god
yeah like
yeah because um yeah if i'm watching
with sydney i am on emotional cleanup
duty i'm like yes it's okay baby don't
worry like i'm i'm like baby like i i
didn't even get my point like i i didn't
even like yeah i guess i guess you can't
really be like oh baby are you okay
hold on give me a second
you've heard about relationships where
the guy comes too fast and then it ruins
it what another one who cries to you
i can't get my tears in she's already
decided it's over before i've even
started yeah because like i remember
because uh i remember because like your
name uh i cried like a [ __ ] baby the
first time i watched your name and it
wasn't even because it was
sad your name was to me the reason is
one of my favorite anime films is
because to me it's like the perfect
cinema experience where yeah there are
so many things happening on screen that
there's like so many emotions um
that i just get so
absorbed that my body doesn't know how
to react other than just crying some
sometimes i get emotional and i don't
know what to do with it and i cry it's
like an overwhelmed cry yeah it's like
it's like an overwhelming music normally
does that for me yeah yeah he's like
like an e key i don't know
it's always the music first black parade
yeah
what is the music did the music will
make me cry instantly
i might hear academia i don't know why i
tear up whenever i [ __ ] hear you say
wrong but like you're screaming yeah why
what's going on yeah i don't really it's
like it's like i've been programmed to
like a certain tune i'm like
it's like pablo yeah yeah i i literally
like yeah
and so i remember i i remember the
second time because the first time i
went by myself uh sorry mark zuckerberg
by the way i know you don't really like
these segments i know you can't relate
to this sorry so the first time i went
by myself um and the second time i was
like sydney you got to see his films
[ __ ] [ __ ] amazing film better come
see with me and i remember it was the
moment just before rad wimps start
playing and that that is that is my that
is the moment where i start crying i
remember i remember i remember sitting
in this film and uh it was the second
time i was getting as emotional i was
getting getting guys into i was like
getting absorbed i'm like
it's it's coming it's coming red ones
are about to play and then like unlike a
minute before like they start playing
i'm just saying
like next to me i'm like oh god i didn't
like it it just took me out and i'm like
i mean it of course it's sydney balling
her eyes out uh yeah that's that's why
that's why as much as i love sydney some
if i'm watching a sad thing
if i want to have an emotional release i
cannot watch you with her
i'm like silly can you stop being
emotional for one second did you watch
his new movie his uh weathering oh
weathering with you
yeah
yes i did watch that did you cry i did
not cry did you cry at um who's the
other director who's good
mama soda
what's his bell
i thought belle was okay
it was
did you say it was mid
okay here's
i watched it by the way oh i i haven't
seen it yet what did you think of it
okay did you watch it in cinemas no
okay i feel like that's a movie you have
to experience in cinemas because
everyone everyone i've talked to who has
seen belle right they've talked about
how it's like a [ __ ] incredible
cinema experience with like the sound
and the music and like
there there are definitely scenes in
bellew and i'm like i get that this it
feels like especially with like the
musical scenes the musical numbers it
feels like these scenes were made to be
to be experienced in a theater with like
with like the surround sound and
everything um in terms of the plots and
everything else it was not his greatest
movie in my opinion was it one of those
movies though that it was like cry bait
yeah
so it's like so it was like the yeah
because because that's what i felt like
you didn't earn it right but that's the
thing is like it's like sometimes it's
so weird with fiction that is like
obvious cry bait yeah where it's like
sometimes it's like yes i will buy into
the cry bait very happily thank you very
much and then there are other times
where it's like okay you don't have to
push this in my face this much like i'll
cry when i want to cry yeah i can cry
they have a digital world in this show
and a movie star and i i just i just
wasn't invested in this world i just
didn't think it was like yeah i couldn't
see it being a thing or yeah why people
would care mm-hmm
because it was like we're just gonna
make um online world we can be anything
except you can't and your avatar's
chosen for you and also yeah there seems
to be like a class system where
uh some people are more important than
others in this world why does that just
sound like someone i was like i was like
it is exactly something
oh okay
yeah
i was like
i agree with you